north korea tested a super emp weapon  that could potentially wipe out nearly  the entire united u.s population so  here's my question how the hell do you  know almost everything is designed to  operate on 120 volts or less  you know that personal that computer  sitting in front of you is probably  operates on on 25 volts you know it's uh  it steps the power down from the but the  outlets  in this in this area put out 120 volts  okay so things that are designed to  operate on 120 volts almost certainly  are not going to survive when you inject  50 000 100 000 200 000 volts at the  speed of light into them you know both  the department of defense and the last  the commission on which i served we  weren't just a paper commission you know  we were about actually testing modern  electronics to see were the electronics  vulnerable we knew they would be  vulnerable but one of the questions we  wanted to know is are they getting more  vulnerable and they are